[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
that's for yourself
[Music]
he goes
hey welcome everybody to the table my
name is Janine
and we're very blessed to see you all
here and I want to extend that welcome
to you guys that are online
um if you're a first time here thank you
for coming you are welcome here
we have a couple of announcements
happy pride month
look
so Dallas Dallas Pride celebrated 40
years this year I don't know if y'all
knew that and the events were held this
weekend but listen you can still get
involved you can wear your colors for
the whole month and there's also of all
places you can go to Good Housekeeping
and they have the top 45
glbtq movies and the top 40 glbtq books
so you can get a little glbtq education
okay tonight at the table we are
celebrating our seniors this is our
first senior celebration isn't that
awesome let's give them a rounded
so we'll be honoring them during the
service and then once we're done with
the service we want to welcome you to
join us for some celebratory treats
during our first Sunday meal at hat
Creek Burger Company in soxie
I hope I pronounced that right I'm not
from around here you get it get the
Texas sexy sexy there you go okay there
we go we got it are any of you
interested in becoming a member of the
table or simply learning more about who
we are or where we are headed
then the welcome to the table class is
just for you we have a class coming up
next Sunday June the 11th from 3 to 4 30
so that's before the service this class
is led by our pastor Brett Tilford and
if you're interested just fill out a
card on the tiny little table in the
hallway and place it in the Box
and now
let's prepare for worship
dear creator
open our hearts to receive your grace
may we hear you call us by name
[Music]
and know our every breath comes from you
amen
start off with some worship so you guys
feel more than welcome to join in
however you feel comfortable there's
space in room and it's an all play so
time for us to lift our voices and feel
at home with a God who is love
[Music]
thank you
that was buried beneath
my shame
who could carry that kind of weed
it was bad to you
I was breathing in the night
foreign
[Music]
that cross
out of the
Darkness into your glorious day
[Music]
now your mercy has saved my soul
now you're freedom is on all that I know
the old made new
just when I met you
my name
[Music]
you call my name
get out of the darkness into your
glorious day
[Applause]
[Music]
let's Club it out
now your love is
[Music]
[Applause]
into your glorious day
[Music]
all right
we're gonna keep going but I want to
dismiss our younger kids our big kids
are going to stay with us tonight in the
service but if you are six years old or
under you can follow Miss Kelly right
over here
thank you Kelly
[Music]
we have
um kind of shifted our first Sundays
um where it's a more communal experience
for our bigger kids because we want our
children to learn to be fully
incorporated into the life of our church
and so
um this first week of the month now on
hat Creek night we also keep our big kid
classroom with us and they're welcome to
sit with their parents or to sit back
there with their other classmates but we
are happy to have you guys with us so
you kiddos feel free to sing along
engage in the worship we're glad to have
you in here with us
[Music]
foreign
human my life with your Holy Fire you
cover me with Grace
[Music]
it is for
Freedom
that I am
say three
broke my chains
[Music]
you are the hand that reaches out to
save I am set free
it is
[Music]
thank you yes Lord we are grateful for
your grace
foreign
[Music]
let's go
it is
thank you
[Music]
set us free
we were practicing through that song
earlier and
um
I just had this thought that so often I
connect Freedom
um
with joy and happiness and I think
definitely there's a for sure connection
there that one is pretty obvious but
tonight I was even celebrating just the
freedom sometimes to name where we're at
and to be where we're at and know that
there's room and space for that
and sometimes that's celebrating the
beauty of transitions the beauty of
moving on the beauty of maybe even just
the good things that are that are
already in your life and and then also
there's room in space there's Freedom
that God has given us to to be seen in
um and for him to be with us also in our
grief and our sadness
in our pain
and he is faithful on both ends
he is present in both spaces
[Music]
and I'm so grateful for the freedom to
be seen and loved like that
this next song may be one that you guys
have seen have have sung 10 million
times if you grew up in the church or it
may be new to you
um but I hope that as we sing it
together that it is a reminder that he
wants to be close with us
that God has made room
to be so present in our lives
and he is not afraid or ashamed of us
but he is near
he is near to us when we are rejoicing
and he is near to the Brokenhearted as
well
so I hope that you find him close
tonight
[Music]
draw me close to you
you never let me go
and lay it all down again
[Music]
to hear you say that I'm your friend
you might desire
thank you
no one else will will do
cause nothing else can take a place
[Music]
to the warmth of your
Embrace
help me find a way
to bring me back to you
[Music]
Street
enjoy
your
your life
[Music]
[Applause]
draw me close
draw me close to you tell me close to
you
Never Let Me Go
I lay it all down again
[Music]
cause nothing else will take your place
help me find a way to bring me back to
you
[Music]
are closer
you are closer
you are closer than my skin
are
closer you are closer
[Music]
were closer than my skin
were closer
and closer
[Music]
than my skin
I will not forget
and I will not forget
who
lives
like
foreign
[Music]
thank you God that we find you closer
than the air that we breathe
closer than our skin
you are our source and our anchor
[Music]
you are the light that guides us
who are the friend
the companion
the father and the mother
[Music]
that we need
would we give you all the space and the
room
that you need
to show us your love
to speak to us
to guide us home
would we open up our heart and our lives
to you
and would you let us
follow hard after you
God would we follow you
with all our soul all our might
in Jesus name we pray these things and
thank you for this time together
amen
all right we are going to move into
graduation Sunday celebrations
um would you guys go ahead and welcome
the people sitting around you introduce
yourself if you don't know who they are
and then our youth team will kick us off
with the rest
foreign
well hi everybody
um I'm waiting for Abby and Marissa to
join us up here our youth team is coming
they're coming
[Laughter]
um
we are here tonight to celebrate our
senior graduates and we've been looking
forward to this night for a long time
and
um there's so much of life that I feel
we are like Dory the fish in the movie
Finding Nemo and it just keep swimming
just keep swimming and I feel like
probably seniors can relate to that more
than anyone at this time of their life
because it's just that final you know
Landmark that you're going for like
we're gonna we're gonna make it we're
just we're gonna finish high school and
it's a big deal you know even in
scripture God always told the children
of Israel like when they came through
something
to stop for a moment and look and
reflect and you know build an altered or
or make a monument or do something to
commemorate the moment and so that's
what tonight is about here at the table
is that we want to commemorate this
Landmark for our seniors and um there's
two seniors that we're celebrating
tonight one is Seth Horvath come on
upset
[Applause]
and the other one text me as we were
starting worship saying I had to leave I
just got sick
so Noel Miner we can show a picture of
Noel
[Applause]
we love you Noel when you watch this
back later
um it's so sad like we were so ready to
celebrate her and um she had a last
minute emergency so
um she's with us in spirit but
um well you get the Limelight now Seth
it's all about you
I had something prepared to say about
each person but let me just say this
about Seth there's I feel like I hear
this phrase all the time that is to you
know to know them is to love them
and to know Seth is to love Seth I think
everyone in this room would agree with
that but yes
but I want to take it a step further to
know Seth is to know what it is to be
loved
that is absolutely I've known Seth since
baby I remember going to your house to
see you when you were born
um and from the moment he came into the
world he's been spreading Joy I kid you
not and I've even had Marissa when Seth
first started hanging out with youth
group she goes okay this kid set seems
to know a lot about me and I don't know
him
yes uh you've now met Seth
Seth you have a gift at knowing people
seeing them noticing them and making
them feel special and that's a beautiful
thing that God's done in you and I'm so
excited to see how that carries forward
so I wanted to um just share a scripture
really fast and then our youth team
wants to pray over you and we have a
gift for you and then we invite all of
you to join us at hat Creek later
tonight we've got cupcakes to celebrate
these two graduates and um
yeah we'll go from there so but the
scripture I wanted to read I was
thinking
when I graduated from high school what
was the thing that I needed to hear what
would have been the most helpful and
honestly it is the thing that I'm still
learning as an adult today
um and I want to read from the Psalms
Psalm 139 says
You O Lord have searched me and you know
me you know when I sit and when I Rise
you perceive my thoughts from afar you
discern my going out and my lying down
you are familiar with all my ways before
a word is even on my tongue you know it
completely oh Lord you him me in behind
and before you have laid your hand upon
me such knowledge is too wonderful for
me too lofty to attain
and then this part especially for our
seniors where can I go from your spirit
where can I flee from your presence if I
go up to the heavens you are there if I
make my bed in the depths you are there
if I rise on the wings of the Dawn if I
settle on the far side of the sea even
there your hand will guide me and your
right hand will hold me fast if I say
surely the darkness will hide me and the
light become night around me even the
darkness will not be dark to you the
night will shine like the day for
darkness is as light to you
Seth as you go forward and Noel wherever
you are right now
I want you to hold this truth in your
heart that there is nothing you can do
and nowhere you can go apart from God's
spirit nowhere wherever your journey
leads you and even if you find yourself
someday thinking what have I done I have
royally messed up even there God's
spirit is with you always the book of
Romans in the chapter 8 says nothing can
separate us from the love of Christ
right not Angels not demons not Heights
nor depths he is always always with you
and we here are right now we can testify
I'm sure each one of us could stand up
and say like uh yeah that has been true
and we have found it and um and we pray
that for you so I'm gonna
who wants to do we were going to have
Michael you want to start and maybe Abby
could finish okay let's
okay uh bow your heads with me please
uh dear Lord together we come to you to
celebrate Seth not as a student anymore
but as a friend and a beloved member of
our community
I pray that going forth
um
he keeps your love with you with him and
um every day that he walks forward with
the strength knowing that
he's just the way that he's supposed to
be
and that um just as Maggie was saying
that there is no corner of the Earth
apart from your love
as uh I'm sure like a lot of us can
relate to is that something that we need
to carry with ourselves and I wish I had
learned that younger and I'm drilling
that into your head right now Seth
um
I have no doubt in my heart that Seth is
going to continue to be a blessing and
inspiration and a light to all those
that come into contact with him and
I just hope that you strengthen and let
that fire burn brighter so that he can
continue to be a beacon for all of us
I'm going to pass it to epby
Seth you are such a light a positive
positive energy you walk into the room
and everyone in the room can feel it you
are just such a wonderful light to us
and our community and we want you to
continue to share that with the world
and everyone you come into contact with
and we are just so lucky to have you as
a part of our community it's in your
name we pray amen
from our team and we'll celebrate more
with you at hat Creek later but we love
you and you guys give Seth a hand
[Applause]
[Music]
ful I um
it's yeah I love little little moments
like that you know just taking taking
time to acknowledge the Transitions and
just a few weeks back I was at a
Quinceanera that was you know kind of
like its own way of doing that you know
I just I feel like that's um
our culture could really use more of
that and the church could use more of
that especially with young people where
even having
um some uh our older kids back here and
included tonight I feel like it's just
part of of us wanting to um do that even
as a church community so all that to say
um Seth Noel we do we love you love you
lots and um cheering you on
so um well it is super good to be with
you all and I want to welcome everyone
and that includes those joining us
online love you all lots and anyone here
who is new tonight uh thank you for
being with us I know it can be a little
bit challenging sometimes to come into a
new space a new place new people and
everyone's like oh they're all best
friends and uh and um we just want you
to know that you are really wanted and
welcomed here
um that's the truth so uh I also want to
give a big shout out a thank you to
Marissa was one of the youth leaders who
was up here and she and and her team
there was a number of volunteers who
went to Dallas Pride to the festival
that was yesterday today's the parade
yesterday was the festival and uh we had
a booth there and she organized all that
and we had folks who you know took slots
to be there to hand out flyers and
um and really just share I mean it was
even Beyond us like saying like Hey
we're the table and you know know about
us it really it's also about churches
being there and having a presence just
just like that's there's something to
that
um
especially in Texas you know just put it
that way I think it's really important
really important so good work uh Marissa
and team were yeah give them a hand
so we are um wrapping up our series
uh titled Easter tide this is not the
end for many of us we grew up you know
with Easter is like very much a one day
thing
um here at the table we've been doing I
know y'all are thinking Easter is long
gone oh not here we just kept going
since April we're just into June now and
um
so we're wrapping up the series this is
kind of our our last message and then
we'll transition to a new series
um next week which uh next week which
I'm really excited about that'll be
titled Sticks and Stones
um rethinking kind of the Bible
scripture
um gender sexuality
um will be be that serious so I hope you
can be back um but for this week the
title of message is a surprising prayer
and one of the cool things about
um sticking with the church calendar
which we do um kind of throughout the
year is uh that this is like kind of the
prescribed lectionary reading
technically it's trendy Sunday it
wouldn't be this Sunday but many of you
know we didn't meet last Sunday so it
kind of went for for last Sunday
um and so it's from John chapter 17
verses 1 through 11.
and it is a rather lengthy prayer but
it's it's interesting because it's Jesus
um praying on behalf of
you
you're cool to think about you know like
I don't know at times we can maybe feel
a little bit distant from Christ uh even
though of course as we were singing
um Christ the spirit is present
um but it's this is beautiful to think
he's actually praying for you uh for us
and so he he said this father
The Hours come glorify your son that
your son may glorify you for you granted
him authority over all people that he
might give eternal life to all those you
have given him now this is eternal life
that they know you the only true God and
Jesus Christ whom you have sent I have
brought you glory on Earth by finishing
the work you gave me to do and now
father glorify me in your presence and
the glory I had with you before the
world began I've revealed you to Those
whom you gave me out of the world they
were yours you gave them to me and they
have obeyed your word now they know that
everything you've given me comes from
you for I gave them the words you gave
me and they accepted them they knew with
certainty that I came from you they
believed that you sent me and now I pray
for them
I'm not praying for the world
I'm but for those you have given me for
they are yours and all I have is yours
and all you have is mine and the glory
has come to me through them I will
remain in the world no longer but they
are still in the world and I am coming
to you Holy Father protect them by the
power of your name the name that you
gave me so that they may be one as We
Are One
it's quite a prayer
quite a prayer
Jesus it's interesting that he closes it
with that that prayer for protection
Holy Father protect them by the power of
your name and you know as I think back
on my own kind of Christian journey and
even have memories of of church like
growing up I was a church kid and uh so
I was you know very much in the kind of
protestant Evangelical World which will
also come up later in the message and
um I I have so many fond memories that
like one was like I think probably the
prayer for protection was like Far and
Away the most popular of all prayers at
least like public prayers
um often it was centered around
traveling I think travel must make us
humans very anxious because that was
like the time where it's like okay it's
time to Circle up you know like whole
church come on here we go everyone hold
hands like this is kind of how he did it
like before I remember being like a
student and before we would go to like
church camp which is only like an hour
drive
but we're circling the whole church up
you know
um the church can't I remember mission
trips of course that makes more sense
um but uh we would start loving I
couldn't I can remember like still had
this image of all of us you know kind of
holding hands and you get like awkward
because you're like worried about your
hands getting sweaty and uh we're all
kind of standing there and I remember
how the person praying they'd have to
like yell because we were outside and so
you know they're just just hollering as
we say in Texas they're just hollering
out this prayer and it was I mean there
was something really beautiful in it
extra bonus points for two things one if
you could pull in the bus driver who
often wasn't part of the Church
community you know it's just like come
on come on join in you know I don't know
where they're if they even wanted to but
they're getting pulled in and
um and then the second kind of bonus
points would be if the phrase traveling
Mercies
could be used that's that's also very
like southern thing I think traveling
mercies Lord traveling mercies for these
youth for the road
it was beautiful and you know it's funny
like you think maybe I'm poking fun but
truth be told like now I find myself
like I also have memories of my parents
even Gathering my brother and I and
praying before road trips like in a
similar way you know and now each
morning like I find myself like you know
kind of saying my prayers and I'm like
Lord protect like everyone I guess us
human beings we're just quivering nerve
endings you know so it's like oh my gosh
protect my my wife and my children and
every single person at the table and
like it's just you know like this is the
the prayer
um and that's beautiful that's good and
I think at first glance
it could maybe sound like that's exactly
where Jesus is going
um as he he mentions in verse 11 you
know if if I will um he says I will
remain in the world no longer right so
it's this idea he's returning to the
father but they are still in the world
right that'd be us
uh and I'm coming to you Holy Father
protect them by the power of your name
right so it kind of where it sounds like
it's going is like okay we're familiar
with this kind of prayer like guard them
protect them keep them from harm you
know traveling mercies or something into
something
um but but if you kind of follow to the
end that is not at all where he goes no
prayers for the protection of your like
fiscal body or something that's not
that's not all where Jesus goes instead
he says this Holy Father protect them by
the power of your name the name that you
gave me what
so that they may be one
As We Are One
that's the prayer
it's it's a prayer yes for protection
it is a prayer for the protection of our
Unity
of our Oneness like of all the things
Jesus could have prayed in that moment
it wasn't like God just you know or
father just just kind of paved the way
may everything go utterly smoothly for
those who follow me or you know like
that's just not not no of all the things
Tech them
protect their Unity
think really kind of in essence it's
like a prayer for the protection of our
heart uh by that I mean like the the
emotional spiritual core from which we
live Jesus was very interested in the
heart always talking about
the inside of us you know our culture
we're obsessed with the outside you know
like how can I look young forever you
know or whatever that's sort of every
commercial you know you can look young
forever you know it's like we're
obsessed with the outer clothing and
Nikes and whatever
um Jesus wasn't so interested in such
things
um really he was really into
you know
that that was his prayer protect their
unity and of course just to be clear
this goes beyond
a prayer for the protection of our
Oneness as in the table you know oh our
unity and Let's Stay Together everyone
you know that's like
um I mean that is I think that's part of
it yes that's true there's something
beautiful about unity and Oneness and
connectedness and community and like
that's beautiful uh but this goes Way
Beyond just the table or you know your
small group your Meetup or your your
Christian friend group or you know
whatever uh this is this is a big prayer
he's he's praying for the global Church
across denominational boundaries across
a churchly theological boundaries all of
it it's it's a prayer for the protection
of our unity and
um I've got to be honest when I've read
this in the past I've often thought uh
or at least where my mind naturally went
was to the the idea of how disappointed
Jesus must be with how things have
turned out
um because you know if you look around I
I don't know if you don't doesn't really
feel like the churches you know we're
just like yeah we're just
Kumbaya you know it's um there's a lot
of fracture there's a lot of Fury and
rage one another and no one really
trusts each other and you know we're
kind of a hot you know we're a hot mess
um and and yet I don't know the more I
kind of pondered it I started to think
like I don't maybe maybe not though
maybe it was maybe Jesus wasn't praying
this prayer with like knowing that you
know this prayers are so powerful and
effective that he could just see it he
could foresee the church and we're just
going to be just walking you know hand
in hand marching arm and arm and like I
don't know maybe actually what if it's
the opposite what if he knew like oh I
mean because well he became human he
knew us real well
and we can't like hardly get along for
seven minutes you know I mean like even
you know families struggle to like stay
unified much less you know entire
communities of you know hundreds of
thousands and millions of people you
know like oh okay like I wonder if maybe
like just what if that was actually
motivating his prayer
was oh yeah
this is this is gonna be a lot
so father protect them protect them
you know um
to me it feels like such a relevant
prayer because if I'm honest
just in my own the last I don't know six
years it's probably some of it's my own
more our own cultural located-ness in
the sense of
it's it's been a polarizing well just
increasingly the the world but we'll
just stick to kind of the culture we're
in American culture is increasingly um
kind of fractured and polarized and
distant and you know all that's
happening
and that influences the church for sure
I mean not that the church was like oh
it's so perfect before 10 years ago not
not in that sense but I just mean I
think it's getting worse
uh and I don't think that's just kind of
hysterical you know it's always getting
every generation thinks like this is the
worst generation I've ever seen you know
I I don't know maybe there's some of
that going on as I'm getting older
um but I do think uh you know you can
kind of track what's happening and it's
it's not great
uh and truth be told I've
I've just I've never
probably some of it's the experience of
leading the table
but I've just never felt
um
more at times distant
from kind of the broader American Church
um and I said my own Protestant Roots
would come up Protestant Evangelical
Roots uh and this would be that moment
I've never felt kind of more distant
um
from from My Tribe
you know and I say My Tribe because like
in ways I do still feel connected
um
you know like it gets I don't know if
you're whatever Church
if you grew up in one I'm not presuming
everyone did if you grew up in a tribe
you know it shapes you powerfully
forever
you know I mean even if you're just like
I'm done with that you know even in the
reaction you're like still connected you
know I mean even in the emotions oh I'm
so angry I hate that you know I mean you
can still see the like oh so you're like
you're really feeling it really hurts
you know what I mean like you can see
that you can I you're just kind of bound
forever you know
um
and I feel like on the one hand there's
such beauty there's such goodness I took
from My Tribe um a few things at least
for me I grew up in some really good
churches not perfect churches but really
some good ones
there was love there and even a lot of
the a certain ethos a culture of the
table has been shaped by that experience
um just a simple kind of loving one
another or at least trying
um I
we've gleaned that from that that
tradition our tribe um appreciation for
scripture you know Maggie probably used
more scriptures in her little talk than
I'll use in my whole sermon
um which is beautiful I mean it's you
know quote in Romans and Psalms and like
that appreciation for scripture that's
that's from our tribe you know
um and I I do I appreciate that um
and um and even like just the personal
kind of Heart to Heart like this idea of
like
um like that song draw me close to you
is like so personal you know and that
that kind of heart that says not just
well I'm religious
I'm a Christian and I do christiany
things but you know with this idea of I
want to love God
I want to know Christ
personally like that's total like
Protestant Evangelical ethos you know
what I mean like it's that and that's in
me that's in me and I appreciate and I
love it
um
so it's not those things it's the other
things
that increasingly through the years I
just find myself
feeling alienated
um distant we I mean I could give lots
of examples but I'm thinking even just
recently the um it's beyond lgbtq stuff
it's broader than that but you know for
our own
um kind of the community we are that's a
relevant one
and just that alone I just feel like
where
where why why not the love
for them too why
and so I just get I just have grown
you know distant
and apparently the feeling's mutual
because
um whenever we would we used to run
Facebook ads we've since abandoned such
things
um
and uh
because we would run an ad you know and
with Facebook's policy you have to be a
little bit careful on how you word
things so we just said things like hey
for the table and we're a welcoming
inclusive Church in Sachse Texas and
we'd love for you to come to our you
know fill in the blank some are on my
kids camp or our Christmas Eve service
and my fellow brothers and sisters in
Christ
um would just some of y'all saw the ads
in the comments like it they weren't
celebrating
um it was a lot of things like oh
welcoming an inclusive we know what that
means
and then it was like little follow-ups
like little Jabs at me I guess because I
was the spokesman like you know and
they're like you Pastor are a wolf in
sheep's clothing boy if I had a dollar
for every time I heard that here would
be a richer pastor
um and I laugh you know and even those
moments I kind of laugh it off I'm
learning to get more in touch with my
feelings as some of my friends and
family know I'm working on it
um so I'd probably laugh it off looking
back I think I probably laughed it off
too quick truth is that that it hurts
it does it hurts
um it hurts and if I'm hurt you know
um how much more many of you
you're it's it's either yourself
um
see your friends your family people you
love you know it's personal
um and we could go into other there's
other topics I don't mean to boil it all
down to lgbtq right but
um
it's a timely one and it's a personal
one for me
and so all that to say yeah I think I
Think Jesus prayer is spot on
protect them protect their Unity protect
their Oneness
protect their hearts
because it is real easy
to get bitter
and cold-hearted
and and angry which can be good you know
anger can be a sign of something
relevant and powerful and good so I'm
not trying to like I don't want to say
anger's bad but the way the way anger
can kind of stick around
for months maybe years you know I mean
that's when it's that what happens it
like um
messes up the heart you know
I think kind of what I'm I'm driving at
is unity in this life
there will probably never be doctrinal
creedal theological
I doubt we're gonna like we'll get
everyone on the same page if we just
work hard enough you know I don't think
so I'd
instead Unity what is it going to be
Unity must be a posture of the heart
of leaning toward the other
rather than away
and I want to acknowledge the complexity
of that too I don't mean that oh so
everyone just lean lean in and press in
no problem you know so easy that's not
what I mean um actually I'm reading a
book right now on um spiritual trauma
Church trauma by Charles Kaiser and
Elaine Heath
um highly recommend it and that's a real
thing right this idea of like sometimes
the pain goes so deep
that it just it hurts so much like
there's all sorts of feelings and so I
think kind of what the invitation
tonight
is for all of us to begin the Journey of
working through it
that's I think that's the invitation and
not in a forced way not in a God won't
love you and like no no no God loves you
that's like that's settled you know
um
if anything just for you
for your own heart and mind for your
children for future Generations because
I think it would be easy for the table
to be on the one hand like worshiping
Jesus
but in the background
become a kind of angry and bittered
community
and
I think Christ is calling us to more
Church he's calling us to more
and we're going to live into it
and you're on your journey if I sit down
with you this is where it's a little
tricky preaching versus speaking with
you one-on-one over coffee right if I
was speaking one-on-one I wouldn't
necessarily speak this boldly to you I'd
probably just listen and you know but
here we are and I'm I'm just trusting
that you hear the heart of this
that that's the call
that they may be one as We Are One
wherever Christians Gather in a spirit
of Grace and listening
rather than judgment and shouting which
by the way can go both ways
the buds of unity begin to bloom
in other words the flower of unity it it
finds its roots in the soil of our
hearts
but as I mentioned like what's that soil
like that's the question that's the
thing Jesus is very interested in
what's the soil like
and I think our call here is to allow
the great Gardener Jesus Christ to
cultivate till fertilize
weed
our own hearts and Minds such that the
healing can begin and oh Lord May the
healing begin for each and every one of
us
in the name of the Father the Son in the
Holy Spirit
amen
amen so as we come to the table of Lord
tonight
as we take in the body of Christ in the
bread
and the blood of Christ in the wine
we
Will May our prayer be Lord make us one
make us one starting right here
in this community and then may it Ripple
out make us one father as you are one
so the way we're going to participate in
communion tonight is we'll start with
kind of the front rows and then we'll
just work our way backwards that way our
line doesn't get insanely long we've
practiced what's called an Open Table
meaning if you're here tonight and you
want to participate then you are free to
do that in the name of unity where you
try to be as ecumenical meaning as
inclusive as possible so if you're
um you know whatever your theology if
there's just there's something in you
that wants to connect with the Risen
Christ
you come forward you come forward and
participate the red is wine the white is
grape juice so you've been warned and
also parents if you want if your kiddos
are back here and you want to like
particip or have them come forward with
you
um you can you know go back and grab
them even their leaders can help you
kind of get connected
um and then finally you can just partake
whenever you'd like so you can take it
immediately you can go to your seat and
partake then however you'd like to do it
all right this is the table
not of the church
but of the Lord and it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more
so come
you who have much faith in you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow and you who
have failed come
because it's the Lord who invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you guys for serving us tonight
with communion
um we're going to close with one song
and if you feel comfortable standing
with us and singing this last song it's
called called me higher and I don't feel
like there could be a more appropriate
song after Brett's message of taking the
challenge of that scripture and living
into that Spirit of unity and not
not just letting ourselves go for the
low-hanging fruit but
but raising the bar of Love raising the
bar of listening
and accepting and also for our graduates
knowing that
you are his and he's calling you to
great things and and um always feeling
that challenge in front of you that God
is calling you forward he is calling you
higher so y'all stand with us and when I
close out the service with this song
[Music]
thank you
I could just say I could just sit away
for all your goodness hope to feel your
presence
I could just stay I could just stay
right where I am and hope to feel you
hope to feel something again
oh
[Music]
I could hold on to who I am and never
let you change me from the inside
ful I could be safe here in your arms
and never leave home never let these
walls down but you have called me higher
you have called me deeper and I'll go
where you will lead me Lord
called me higher
you have caught me deeper and I'll go
where you will lead me Lord you'll Lead
Me
[Music]
I could hold us
called me higher you have called me
deeper and I'll go where you will lead
me Lord
you have called me higher you have
called me deeper and I'll go where you
will lead me Lord
you've called me higher you have called
me deeper and I'll go where you will
lead me
Lord you'll Lead Me
[Music]
you'll leave me alone
I will be yours
[Music]
and I will be yours oh I will be yours
for all my life
will be
on my life so let your mercy light the
path before me
High
[Music]
deeper and I'll go where you will lead
me Lord
you have called me higher you have
called me deeper and I'll go where you
will lead me
you
you have called me higher you have
called me deeper and I'll go where you
will lead me Lord you'll Lead Me
you'll Lead Me
[Music]
oh my goodness are y'all blessed I know
I am
so thank you so much for joining us this
evening and if you're new we would like
to get to know you better so if you'd
fill out a card on the table out in the
hallway put it in the little box and
that will allow us to follow up with you
it'll allow us to answer any questions
that you might have and to just say
thank you for you visiting with us
my name is Janine and if you are in need
of prayer or a hug or just general
support then come find me after the
service I'll also be at hat Creek so you
can find me there
and I would love to be there with you
however I can
here at the table we are committed to
creating an inclusive christ-centered
community that touches lives and
generosity is a key component of that
mission so if you're willing to join us
in this we want to invite you to go to
thetabletexas.org or the tiny little box
on the table in the hallway and support
this work financially
remember next Sunday is our welcome to
the table class before service
for more information or to register for
that again go to that tiny little table
in the hallway and fill out one of those
cards
don't forget join us for our celebration
of our seniors
and now
if you'd like to assume a stance of
receiving a blessing I would love to
send you out into your week with this
one
you are a child of God
this is true on your best day and it's
true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet un yet to be determined highs
and lows and everything in between go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved that you are worthy and you are
accepted just as you are and go filled
with God's Holy Spirit and the desire to
extend these same Gifts of Grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
into contact with
be blessed and have a great week we hope
to see you at happy
[Music]
oh I will be yours
I will be yours
thank you